we're with ray robson one of the early
leaders in this event but
not to be ray you got the black pieces
against wesley so in the last round the
only chance is to win no one wants that
tall order what were your thoughts
coming into the round and then as far as
the opening was concerned the way the
game transpired
yeah no i didn't really come into it as
like this is my chance uh this is like
you know i have a good chance to win or
anything i just tried to play normally i
mean i think for for first place my
chances were really obviously in the
game with fabi i needed to not lose that
game i shouldn't have ever lost that
game and then
i had two whites near the end against
bruzone and john burke decent chance to
at least get one win there i wasn't able
to get a win in either those two games
so i thought those are my real chances
this game against wesley um yeah i just
played normally uh he played
super solid line there was really not
anything
i could do in terms of trying to fight
for a win in terms of the preparation we
saw you think for about 20 minutes on
the move bishop b7 was this still part
of your prep or were you trying to
remember what to do yeah i just got very
confused because i went to play the line
that we got in the game but uh
there's different move orders so i
didn't have to like take on c4 and move
seven i could play let's say b6 first so
just during the game when i was thinking
about bishop b7 when i played it i just
suddenly became very concerned like what
if he goes rook c1
yeah bishop b7 what if rook c1 he just
tries to take my pawn and then let's say
h6
bishop takes f6 queen takes f6 queen
takes c7 bishop takes f3 e takes f3
queen takes d4 and
ah just like visually i was very
worried at first so i didn't really
consider this line too much because just
i can't develop my queen side pieces so
if he even just develops uh
it seems like i just lose but then later
i realized that probably concretely it's
just working because let's say i'm going
to take on b2
um let's say he plays bishop e2
queen takes b2 and not only is my queen
always tying his queen down by hitting
his rook on c1 but also i'm preventing
him from castling because i hit the
bishop on e2 like if he could just
castle safely here even though i'm up a
pawn i don't didn't see how i'm
developing but
yeah i realized eventually that this
seems to be working out so
yeah i thought maybe i'd messed up the
move order but
i i think i hadn't but i just had to see
this line
so then given that you were prepared the
rest of the way you seem to be moving
very quickly yeah so yeah then it
transfers into stuff that i kind of
remembered yeah h6 wesley had a game i
think against magnus where he took on d7
took on f6 and
he played this novelty like d5 i think
um that's exactly right and i believe he
even won that game that was a draw oh he
drew maybe he was better though uh but
yeah this is an interesting line but
okay he played bishop h4 in the main
line
um
and yeah then he went f3 which is not
the most common i don't think but if i
remember right there is a game between
dioch uh bogdan dietch versus gelfind
which i think i followed with queen
knight takes and queen e7 here i think
he played queen d6
and then queen takes d6 rook takes d6
and black should be fine i remember one
of the ideas black could play here which
should be equal is knight d5
idf e4 we play knight e3
and the bishop has to protect g2 so
we'll take off that bishop and
should be should be a drill
so in the game he played e4 which i
didn't know but
um
i mean there was
really no risk for for me it seemed like
i had this simple idea bring the rook to
c5 and if he moves the queen back i have
g5 which could actually be dangerous for
him so i don't think he's ever able to
maintain his two bishops here
all right so your assessment overall of
this championship you're a veteran of
these now having played in many
of these campaigns
i'm sure you are not thrilled that you
had a great chance from the beginning
but were not able to deliver
yeah well mostly i'm disappointed in the
the fobby game um
i mean that was
really really heartbreaking game and
i was very very upset with a couple of
my decisions there
because basically i had
the game drawn i mean if i played one
move differently in the early middle
game which
i had
planned to from the start
i don't think
i don't think he could do anything there
in the game he got some chance to at
least push
and obviously
it's hard to defend for a long time
um
but yeah otherwise
it was it was all right i think i didn't
play like amazingly i just played my
normal level um
yeah it's super it's tough tournament
like everyone is is really well prepared
and obviously very strong
so
i don't know you could say maybe
everyone is like all the top guys were
not playing their best but i think just
also competition is
really difficult
even the
few people who might be targeted uh i
mean they did lose a couple games but in
general they're still very very solid so
yeah i think it was just a very strong
event i'm
really happy i got the uh the chance to
play
and definitely a lot to learn
that's my question for you next question
what's the lesson what's the takeaway
how do you improve so that you can
come back stronger next year
um i think there's
lots of different things i mean
one one of the things that i think
separates the top guys is they're just
so
i mean everyone's well prepared but
they're like
not only well prepared but like well
prepared in every line in every opening
and seems like
they remember everything
um so i think i still need to do a lot
of work in that regard
um to try to improve there
uh
yeah i mean in in those two last white
games i had i didn't really get real
chances so probably i need to think
about
my approach
in general with white because i think
with black overall was pretty solid
but with white
those two games i guess i need to figure
out a way to
to put more pressure on my pawns at
least you can never force the win but
i don't know if i just need to be better
prepared or
play different openings
but um
yeah overall it i'm not unsatisfied uh
it was it was all right but just
unfortunate that i had such a good
chance to at least get to a playoff and
obviously i didn't quite make it
all right looks like some going back to
the drawing board and get those lessons
very important of course as you know
after every tournament congrats on a
fine result and
better luck next time thanks great very
very quick question i mean you were dorm
mates with wesley and well you certainly
crossed swords with him at the blitz
tables and uh did it ever flash through
your mind that you know i
we were we were best of buddies at one
point and you know we we grew up
together playing chess
uh does that ever enter your mind uh
these
nice memories of collegiate dates
um yeah i guess occasionally
uh yeah i guess we've played each other
so many times since then um
that doesn't really cross my mind that
much also we've been uh teammates in the
olympiad
a few times
so yeah i i don't think about it that
much i mean we're still
friends but obviously it's different
we're not you know living together like
before
um
yeah i remember actually we reached the
final against each other of the
millionaire chess in 2014 spoke about
that yeah 150 000 at stake
yeah where we were uh yeah i think we
were still roommates at webster maybe
and actually i think also during the
tournament we were roommates at the
tournament so that was uh
yeah we've obviously had some some good
memories that that room took home 150
000
i would like to have some money on that
congratulations on a hardcore tournament
good luck in your career are you going
over to riga are you going i'm not i'm
not playing i'm not going to go to the
fide uh swiss event not this time that
was actually my
basically my last tournament two years
ago was the
isle of man in 2019. wow so
all right thank you rick
congratulations 150 thousand highlights
from the same room